grief is well boring right I mean we all
think we want to be helpful and
sympathetic or maybe get mentioned in a
big Facebook post that the grieving do
as someone who helped me through my
terrible time but do you really want to
hang out with someone that you just
cannot cheer up no matter what
absolutely no way my sister died of a
brain tumor in 2011 she had a fit on my
dad in his car and he had to rush her
into a walking center in his arms
it was lucky it was that sister who got
rushed into the walking center because
if it had been me in fact to dragged me
in by Oh me ankles she died on April
24th 2011 and I was the last person to
get to the hospital
behind secondary members of my family I
remember being really peed off that
there were so many people in the room
with us that there was no privacy and
why the eff was either last she was my
sister there was only two years
difference and she and I danced together
for 10 years we shared a room together
for 10 years and she was the one who
protected me from bullies at school they
say that the only two things in life you
can be sure over death and taxes and I
find it really funny that you don't get
taught about boats at school I learned
how to poke rats at hot water or
learning how to comfort my parents I
learned how to put a condom on a banana
but I don't know how to talk to my
brother about my sister I'd rather cry
on a stranger on a bus and hear one more
person ask are you okay that ever so
rehearse to face a sympathy that people
think they have to do because they saw
it in Four Weddings and a funeral my
friends of course were very supportive
but two or three years of the same story
the same bad mood the same sadness over
and over again it really wears people
dying life moves on and so should you if
you can there's some people that don't
think they can and that's perfectly okay
I hear people talking about how people
dance around the subject of death I
think since the rise of social media
people aren't doing that as much
nowadays these days people love a bit of
death grief trolls I call them people
who get from the drummer who you know
yeah women are the worst offenders of
this I'm sorry girls but you are
attaching themselves to the grieving and
getting all up in our business so they
seem very important during
really intense time I mean people really
have no idea what to do
also I'll be perfectly honest I'm seven
years out of it and I could have bet it
now but I love the attention don't get
me wrong I would have had my sister back
in a nano minute I spent my entire
childhood with this gorgeous old a
popular dance with sister taking all of
the limelight and now people were
noticing me Wow the trouble is however
when I got the attention I'd always
wanted
it was now tainted with an emptiness
that would never go away the universe
gave me all that I'd ever wanted which
was to be notice but I paid the price
for it like someone comes over that's a
little top hat poop on my good mood
something will always rain on my parade
so I made up a way to cope with
everything I had this idea called Island
Jade I imagined that my life was an
Ironman and it was my Island I am judge
jury executioner president Queen Prime
Minister and god of other people from
other islands what to come on to it they
can but there is a list of rules and if
they don't add ear to the list of rules
then I won't let down the drawbridge I'd
say that grief has given me a sort of
Incredible Hulk level of strength the
worst thing that could ever happen to me
is happens now it means I'm
indestructible even when I am vulnerable
I call it special Club it's a really
terrible way that you get into the club
but once you're in it's like you know
like the Freemasons but our secret
handshake is a hug a knowing nod or a
wink
[Music]
you